[Music]
this morning in our reporters notebook
series we look to the stars for a change
of perspective out in a moment of near
disaster we see how preparedness and
partnership helped to find the calm in
the most demanding situations how was
your workweek
did you get an irritating email did your
soul wither on a conference call liftoff
of the soyuz ms 10 new keg had a rough
day on the job recently he was on his
way to work when suddenly he found
himself zooming towards the planet at
twice the speed of sound and seven times
the force of gravity the pressure he was
at the pointy end of a rocket headed to
the International Space Station when it
malfunctioned for the weary business
traveler mechanical difficulties mean we
have to go see the gate agent Haig had
to check the valves orientation and talk
to rescue crews on the ground all while
spinning like a Vitamix hey again his
Russian copilot alexey ovchinin knew
what to do because they'd been
practicing emergencies for two years the
hard diligent non flashy work that
prepared them when something went wrong
they spoke in Russian as they had in
training Americans now ride to space on
Russian Rockets this would seem like
science fiction to an American of 15
years ago when the space race was a
proxy which country could blow up the
other faster but this time the Russian
technology on the Soyuz rocket had saved
an American Life
and that American after he touched down
shook the hand of the human next to him
and the two joked about how short the
flight advanced training can give you
grace under pressure but I don't know
where Hague got his equanimity he
crashed called his wife left her
voicemail told her he was okay
and later he told reporters sometimes in
life you don't get a vote we just have
to roll with the punches
space exploration isn't just about
discovering things we don't know it's
about revealing things we know but may
have forgotten the beauty of cool
headedness the value of preparation our
common humanity and the inspiration that
can be found in defeat the right stuff
while the rocket may have crashed Hagan
ov Keenan still give us all something to
shoot for they really do it was amazing
that they both survived and were able to
joke about it they don't capture them
brilliantly and it's reminder there's
more that unites us sometimes than
always dividing us right yeah and when
you listen to what they had to do for
two basically two years they found all
the different ways that could go wrong
yeah
paired for that and thank goodness they
did the training kicks in he left his
wife a voice note indeed